NBA Finals party I need to sign off on
the guest list
hey do you invite the kid you said keep
it sophisticated why do you hate fun
invite the kid can I please shave us off
no you may not because your team lost
therefore you have to look like me which
one go for third option
get out Friday run a final check on the
party list question Captain Steve Rogers
too soon sending invite no way I'm gonna
watch the NBA Finals with mr. stork so
you're gonna let me go ha nice try buddy
[Music]
finally here we go good evening Peter oh
you have 576 possible shooter from the
nation ha ha ha I can keep that stood
yeah done fit me where's our next
retreat
what next mission we'll call you all
right it's not a hug him to scram the
tow for you
all right there yet all right kid good
luck out there
hey Peter you coming tonight I can't
tonight I got the stark internship
what's up guys
mister here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grand theft bicycle okay
could you do me a favor hold on to that
there's anybody fight I helped us the
old lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute
you guys on the real event just hope
gives it away you move I'm working on
he's working for crazy dangerous listen
Peter are people who handle the sort of
thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys time we
changed too
this is my chance to prove myself we
have a Spanish quiz you gotta get better
at this part of the job I'm sad oh I'm
intimidating
are you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just kidding hunger by
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol I'm sick of mr.
stark treating me like a kid but you are
a kid yeah you can stop a boss with his
bare hands
[Music]